[Musique]
tu repars quand je vais prier pour votre
papa je pas Charlie on va redémarrer ça
ensemble avec quel argent c'est à toi
d'assurer maintenant c'est du
délire c'est temporaire j'ai regardé les
sites d'escorte ici y a que dalle si on
se professionnalise on peut vraiment
tout déchirer et parce qu'il faut
retirer le t-shirt en plus ah [__]
contre qu'on assure on va pas se louper
faut qu'on passe la vitesse supérieure
mais
on est en train de parler de
prostitution on est toujours la put de
quelqu'un n'importe quoi tu bébé toi je
un bébé bien
[Musique]
équipé vous avez
hte ça s bien passé ta cl je pense à
quelqu'un d'autre je suis paumé je plus
rien tu pas Mar de servir à rien tu veux
que je fasse quoi dis-moi tu veux que je
fasse quoi de ma vie tu passes ta soirée
à te frotter tu veux faire tu t'en fous
des meuf sais faire ça c'est pas normal
je sais j'ai tué ma
famille
[Musique]
merci mieur bienvenue dans la cour des
grands